just oronzo è passato solo qualche
giorno da quando la tua fidanzata
valentina ha deciso di porre fine alla
vostra storia
oggi tu ci hai chiesto di poterla
incontrare per quale motivo voglio
chiederle scusa per tutte le mie cose ce
l'ha mi è basta voglio tornare sei
convinto sia assai assai come ti senti
adesso ma le pare
ma tema però voglio davvero ad essere
voglio dire tutte ste cose
buonasera
cogliamo l'orgoglio togliamo tutto che
devo chiedere scusa per tournée mi fate
con 8 per tutte le botte non tenete a
prima di partire
quando sto facendo la valigia tu hai
detto è dimenticato qualcosa e io ho
risposto sì gli occhiali se tu mi hai
detto che ti sempre occhiali per
guardare le altre non ti voglio più gli
occhiali per chi vuole guardare solo te
perché sei la donna della mia vita
creati per stato malissimo bellissimo e
lo devi dimostrare anche fuori sono
stanca io ho bisogno di certezze oro
ogni certezza sei tu sei tu noi sono
stato messo male malissimo mai mai ma
devi mettere la testa apposto rho
credimi non voglio mettere la testa a
posto
la pista napoli mette sulle spalle sulle
spalle ma quando mette ha bisogno di due
minuti per pensare un attimo scusate
io l'altra possibilità te la do vediamo
come stai
lo dico col cuore ma la testa col gol ma
voglio che lo pensi davvero quando visi
mancata o rosa
devo farti questa domanda anche se penso
che la risposta sia abbastanza ovvia
decide di tornare a casa da solo o con
valentina con la mia donna valentino
anche a te devo fare la domanda decide
di tornare a casa da sola o con robson
la sala ragazzi
potete finalmente tornare a casa insieme
baglioni sono stati quando si soffre per
amore
il consiglio di un amico può essere
fondamentale
ecco perché ad insaputa di da saper
arrivare a tempe shawn heins una sua
amica una donna che viene dal mare
ehi guarda chicca tesoro ne sono venuta
tanto gotico porto la mia jarmo ti
voglio bene non mi poteva più fare il
regalo migliore grazie
dai amore so come stai tesoro male male
ci sono creduto io questa cosa non so se
ce la faccio
la solar sa devi essere forte
vorrei scappare village e la boutique
andare avanti perché lo devi fare per te
stessa e come ho fatto che io a suo
tempo deve arrivare fino alla fine devi
trovare delle risposte forse non ho
capito niente dall'inizio
adesso ti faccio vedere una cosa che la
terrà sul come pino e la brace rai nei
momenti di sconforto
però mi deve promettere di non piange
promessa guarda che cosa ti ho portato
è tantissimo che non ha un peluche nella
vita da quando ero piccolo ma veramente
lo terrò per tutta la mia vita con gli
occhi a miano
diamogli un nome dai amore infatti tele
volevo suggerire le sai c'è sempre
memoria sulle labbra galoppo telmo io lo
amo e ricordo amore ma devi andare
avanti perché non esiste solo lui ci sei
prima di tutto tu e il tuo bambino va
bene non so se mi pensa se a me mi manca
tantissimo amore mio non si costruisce
una storia sulla paura adesso devi
andare avanti mi prometti grazie giorno
ti voglio bere
[Musica]
è